will answer your questions but you must
first transform back to Jennifer why
[Laughter]
[Music]
another problem
is expensive they played the wakandan
drums
they all know yeah what do they know
they know everything oh even the writers
to the show Runners do they know they
know
what are they cooking welcome back to
New Rock Stars last Friday Victoria
Alonso the VFX head of Marvel Studios
left and with her leaving raises many
questions seen as she was the one that
was leading a lot of the VFX upsides and
downsides over at Marvel also leading a
big initiative to bring in diversity in
as well so this means a lot but like
what does it completely mean for the
next Marvel projects what does this mean
for the VFX overall at Marvel will we
get crazier VFX better worse VFX also is
this part of Bob iger's restructuring of
Disney I don't know but we're gonna get
into it all today in this inside Marvel
this is new Rockstar's weekly Marvel
reaction show I'm Jessica lemons here
with me is Mt and Eric hey what's going
on Jessica hi hi yeah um probably the
biggest shakeup we've seen at Marvel
since uh the beginning right yeah like
she's been there since like the first
Iron Man right yeah she's been there
forever and she went from like she was
pretty high up still working on Iron Man
it's not like she was like a at PA like
Kevin feige was or whatever to X-Men uh
I think he was a sip was he a sepia or
was he a producer on X-Men Kevin he was
the producer's assistant on X-Men the
previous uh Lauren Schuler Donner's
assistant and then he just was a nerd in
the room yeah she was like still a
pretty high up person in post-production
when she was working on Iron Man but she
still worked her way up to work directly
under Kevin feige and now we don't know
if she's she hasn't we don't know if
she's been let go we just know that she
left so
we're gonna we're gonna speculate a
little bit on what that can mean just
because the future of Marvel Lucy and
the person that was like the head head
of visual effects and post-production
has just now left so there's a lot of
questions we have with all these pushes
it's tea time yeah be sure to check out
nerdriot.shop where you can always grab
the latest and greatest new rockstars
gear right now you can check out our new
line of merch inspired by the
Mandalorian season three support our
Channel and check out our great merch
options over there on nerdride.shop I
think my boys were in the Baba Yaga tea
look at that
um
um RS R.I.P Lance Reddick we love you oh
yeah
papa papa and don't forget to subscribe
to our newest Channel The Deep dive Eric
just dropped the Marvel remove story
Lines video and this investigation and I
agree with it completely wholeheartedly
it is so insane I was also like when I
was watching Eric's uh the breakdown of
this I was just like at the very
beginning I was like Kevin answer why is
this missing why did you take this out
and there's a lot actually in it that
involves a lot of the VFX that happened
and a lot of maybe what can tie to her
leaving we had we had been working on
that one for a couple weeks and then
suddenly this news dropped and I'm like
we got to drop this today like this is
it answers all of our a lot of our
questions but raises more yeah well it's
also just surprising how much for me at
least it was surprising to recognize how
much of a lot of the pushing like in
dates is because of reshoots or just
reshoots because of post-production or
visual effects had to be altered and I
was like because it's so expensive it's
so expensive and you're resourcing not
only within house you're doing outside
of this outside of the Marvel Studios
you're doing the Freelancers so it's
like so much commotion you saw what
Kevin said about uh she-hulk's looks it
takes a lot either way you guys and if
you're planning on being at WonderCon
this year new rockstars will be doing a
live panel this Friday March 24th at 2
30 p.m we'll be doing a fun live show
completely different than anything you
seen on this channel so be sure to stop
by and say hi it's going to be me Zach
Eric Tommy and a lot of guests um
friends and family of new rockstars will
also make a little appearance that's
this Friday March 24th at 2 30 pm at
WonderCon I'll sign your baby's head
okay now to the middle of the discussion
no more signing babe no more kissing and
signing babies you guys
uh like people want to know who is
Victoria Alonso I made a rhyme on
purpose so
really quick I'm gonna give you guys a
rundown that I'm going to give you the
question Victoria Alonso has been with
Marvel Studio since Iron Man she was the
chief of visual effects and
post-production then over the years she
worked all the way up to president
physical and post-production visual
effects and animation production that's
a long title and if you're in Hollywood
you notice that after a certain amount
of time you just start making up your
title so it looks like you do everything
when you do do everything you just kind
of have to bulk it together uh she
basically does work directly under Kevin
feigilo so that's a big thing now she
oversaw Juan Division and She-Hulk but
she most recently worked on Ant-Man and
the WASP Quantum Mania she'll also be
accredited as a producer for the
Guardians 3 the Marvel's secret invasion
ironheart Echo and Agatha coven of chaos
I don't necessarily want to like
speculate on what she did as a human
because there's there I don't know what
what's going on behind the scenes I do
know that there's rumors that like she
did make a really hard work environment
for a lot of the VFX people going uh
working in the Marvel Studios so if you
do want to talk about it feel free to
add on to it personally
um I just want to know what does this
mean for visual effects overall at
Marvel because we know they're under
Fire like I said earlier for like
unhealthy work conditions and labor for
the VFX teams or Freelancers so like
with her leaving does this mean that it
gives more way for bigger projects to
prosper or are we gonna kind of get a
little speed bump of like momentum to
the visual effects Ah that's such a yeah
that's an interesting question and as
just said there's just a lot we don't
know we're still waiting on a statement
from Marvel as of this taping but I
think one thing that we can all agree on
is the scale of the output of Marvel
Studios drastically increased between
2019-2021 and uh and I'm getting into a
lot of debates with people on Twitter
right now while still Marvel has bad
writing well still Marvel's doing a lot
of reshoots the writing quality at
Marvel in my opinion has stayed roughly
the same like the the style of writing
you can't you can't numerically grade
writing you can say maybe you don't uh
you don't relate or you don't connect to
the writing but I would say it's still
kind of the jokey ironic detached style
of self-referential uh-ness that has
been there since phase one when when
John Favre was directing these movies
and and Josh Whedon was writing these
scripts it's it's still the same overall
kind of style and they did a lot of
reshoots on those movies and still
tinkered with these movies in
post-production uh but what has changed
is the scale and it's really hard to to
balance all that uh now good VFX can be
done on streaming uh I think there's
some great VFX work that has been done
in Star Wars uh I think there's some
great VFX work that's been done in Game
of Thrones The Last of Us some pretty
good VFX work I think there's a lot of
people on Twitter who's claim to be VFX
experts and don't know what they're
talking about those giraffes are
definitely fake
yeah those giraffes were real in The
Last of Us what you were relating to is
its connection to a blue screen and you
think that the thing in front of the
blue screen is fake but no it's the
background that's fake so people don't
know what they're talking about
um but what is clear is that it's hard
to have all these things connect if
you're going to be directing and
producing movies this way that rely so
much on previz you really have to have a
tight ship of True Believers who all
believe and understand the cause and you
see that at lucasfilm like the artists
who work at lucasfilm are super pumped
and super excited
um and uh and and are really excited to
bring things like the myth to Star to
life at Marvel I think a lot of people
because there's so much secrecy they
don't know what they're working on so
they're like you're just asking me to to
animate Ant-Man a giant Ant-Man punching
things and I have no idea what where
he's going and I'm just kind of like I'm
burnt out now and I don't know what the
plan is so it's I think it's a
combination of all these things of
secrecy of the amount of output and the
amount of interconnectivity and the last
minute requests uh if you go back and
watch interviews from Infinity War the
VFX supervisor and the Russo brothers
and the writers are in lockstep like
they're excited to work together now you
don't see that you don't see the VFX
artists on these interviews together
it's all behind closed doors I think
that's a good uh a good thing to jump
off of too or not jumping point but like
good to nail in and remind ourselves
that like uh animation and visual
effects takes so much time and so much
hard work and people like eight hours is
actually like 12 hours and like 12 hours
is actually a week and you're working on
just making this movement happen from
this person jumping and it takes a lot
of teamwork it takes a lot of help and a
lot of support and you guys all need to
feel like you really want to work on
this to put that love and work into it
and that's why I'm like
it
and I'm not a person that understands
visual effects I'm not gonna act like I
freaking do I went to school for editing
and every time I had to do after effects
I was so confused at what I was making
but and that's why I'm always like I
don't think it's that bad but it's also
like
you need I think Marvel does need to
give them more time we need to give them
more time and we can't keep letting
directors
restructure things we can't have people
last minute I love the Russo brothers
and I don't think they do this a lot but
I know that there's directors that'll be
like no we need to cut this and reshoot
this and it's like it doesn't work like
that you can't fix everything in post
sometimes once it gets to post you let
them handle it and they have an
allocated amount of time before it
either goes overseas or it takes them
forever to work on it so I'm like I
think this is uh this step is towards
something giving Marvel more time on the
what they have at hand versus blasting
out a bunch of things with and forcing
people to go from She-Hulk to wakanda
forever to all these other different
properties but yeah do you think it's
the director's restructuring things or
do you think it's a studio having like
taken stuff off the director's plate and
restructuring those parts I think it's
both I think the studio is working to
restructure things to make it easier but
I don't know if the studio works that
closely with the directors because we
switch director so often uh we don't
real like Ryan coogler we kept on two
yes we did we keep a lot of them on too
but some of them have only done one
movie like uh what's her name Chloe Zao
that did eternals she'll come back for
his eternals too but right now she only
has one and it's like we move these
directors in and out so quickly
including the series that it's like we
don't have enough time to give them the
rundown of what to do so I think the
studio is like this is what a new like a
director should do but it's like not all
directors work like that and you need to
be ready for the directors that don't
work inside your box to like just give
them a little note that's just me that's
just me that's me working in production
since I've been in La that I'm like yeah
sometimes it gets really hard and
sometimes it's the directors or the EPS
that are like we'll fix it in post uh
empty I'm sorry what were you gonna say
no I was just gonna ask like do you guys
think that like um because of this this
head of VFX sort of leaving the Marvel
do you guys think that we'll see delays
in like you know Secret Wars Kane
Dynasty like all the like the face five
um I guess and that maybe I should go to
the face six like phase five stuff like
do you think with some delays in in
projects to as they restructure and
she's still a producer for like the
marbles for secret Invasion for AG of
the coven of chaos so I think those ones
she worked on still so it's the the
little ones like armor Wars maybe not
the ones further down the line yeah I
think I mean when it comes to what
they're credited on the work that
they've already done on these projects
that's more of like a PGA like a just
like an industry standard thing the work
you've done like James Gunn still got
credit on like Infinity war and end game
despite the fact that at the time he was
away from Marvel you know
um the I think what we're gonna see
um we are already in the process of
seeing delays the Marvel's already got
delayed secret invasions coming out a
bit later than we thought Loki's coming
out a little bit later than we thought
but I think that's all part of a bigger
picture that we'll talk about as we keep
going through this episode but I think
what we will see I think as part of
Victoria Alonso TV in the studio
maybe some of these titles that they
announced for phase five might now be
roped in with other things like rather
than seeing like I just would not be
surprised if rather than seeing an echo
series we see Echo as part of the front
lineup for Kang Dynasty
um like I just it's gonna be hard for
them I think they're big tent poles Kang
Dynasty Secret Wars they're gonna try to
stick to those as much as possible
because those are still important dates
for Disney shareholders and they're
gonna want to hit those release dates
but some of these Disney plus titles
might now be folded into some of those
big tent poles instead of being their
own thing yeah I think it's interesting
because it's like Loki
it's so interesting to figure out what
their temples are because I would assume
a Loki is definitely number one or one
of them one of them I assume Guardians
is also another one of them
um but
they're gonna end up pushing I know
they're gonna end up pushing Kang
Dynasty and Secret Wars
[Music]
I think they're not by a lot it's not
gonna be like a full year but I think
they are gonna push it down the line
especially because like we don't I don't
think blade directly infects that but I
think blades gonna maybe get pushed one
more time and
some other properties so see I think the
big ones they're just like I think they
would be less willing to ship those big
ones because just an Avengers title
coming in May of some year it's like
yeah I figured like they would move
everything else out of the way just to
hit that just to make sure that Disney
had a good year that year yeah you know
but what we're less likely to see
guaranteed to stay in their spot are
some of these other sequels like things
like blade uh things like uh you know
um New World Order like Thunderbolts
like I I'd be I'd be surprised if
Thunderbolts kept its spot but Kang
Dynasty didn't that's what I'm saying
yeah you can't have your these little
even those little hiccups for the tinier
shows it's like those people are still
gonna show up in either Kang Dynasty or
Secret Wars so it's like you can't
really shift it too much because we
still got to keep them and there is like
a rumor that like Fantastic Four
wouldn't appear in secret Wars or
something like that and it was right
what is going on I think it was loveness
was asked if he was using the Fantastic
Four I think and he's like no they're
not really on my plate but I think yeah
but now we're also hearing rumors that
like Loki is gonna now factor into like
the Fantastic Four like I think they're
reconfiguring who their lineups are
gonna be uh and I think that's affecting
like who gets spin-offs uh like
it's just interesting we saw a d23 a
trailer for ironheart and we saw a
trailer for Echo and now I'm looking at
the Slate ahead and it's like does
Marvel need both those shows I'm like I
want to watch both those shows but like
I think they're on the chopping block
really they could be that it would be
what DC did and that's just like DC kind
of has this is a bad thing to say and I
don't mean it to heart but DC kind of
has the money to lose I don't know if
Marvel has the money to lose like that
like Bob Iger doesn't want to lose money
because they already shot so much of it
of both those things that it's like to
put it on the chopping block maybe push
it but put on the job I actually we're
gonna get into this because the next
question is about Bob iger's
restructuring plan which just completely
comes in full swing with uh so we'll get
back to inside Marvel but first we'd
like to take a moment to thank our
sponsors the hell bring inside Marvel to
you if you're one of those folks that
has a yard you probably are dreading
spending your weekend taking care of it
leave that dread behind and reclaim your
weekend son day Lawn Care can take one
thing off your to-do list instead of
spending time working on your yard with
Sunday you can spend time enjoying it
Sundays everything you need to get the
lawn you've dreamed of this spring go to
getsunday.com Marvel and enter your
address to get your customized plan
created just for your lawn no trips to
the store or hauling heavy bags since
they ship straight to your home you just
need a house to apply Sunday you can
fertilize your whole lawn in less time
than it takes to watch an episode of
your favorite TV show and they can only
use ingredients you can feel good about
no harsh chemicals no long waiting
periods or trying to keep your kids and
pets off that lawn get those kids off my
lawn yeah simply apply let it dry and
you're back to enjoying your yard not
the kids yard your yard Sunday is easy
and affordable some lawn care services
cost more than 1500 a year but Sunday's
full season plans start at 109. and
Sunday's offering our listeners 20 Off
full season plans start at just 109 and
you can get 20 off when you visit
getsunday.com Marvel at checkout that's
20 off your custom plan to get
sunday.com Marvel and while we're
waiting for our next piece of sweet
sweet Marvel content we might as well
get a great night's sleep and for years
we here at new rockstars have trusted
our sleep to Helix Helix makes premium
mattresses and bedding that are
accustomed to fit your needs and
conveniently shipped right to your door
which Helix mattress is right for you
don't worry about it Helix made a sleep
quiz that matches your unique body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you and based on your
different sleep positions and fitness
preferences they have something for
everyone's unique taste and if you sleep
with a partner you can take the Sleep
quiz together and find something that's
the perfect compromise for both of you I
freaking love my Helix mattress I sleep
on it every night and it is it helps me
just sleep like a baby I feel like a big
old baby sleeper and the best part about
all of this is that Helix delivers your
mattress right to your door it was quite
amazing when I got it I was like how is
there a mattress in this box is this
astronaut technology I don't understand
with free shipping in the US and plus
Helix has a 100 100 night sleep trial so
you get more than three months to make
sure that you love it or get a full
refund Helix mattresses have a 10 year
warranty and they even offer financing
options and flexible payment plans so a
great night's sleep is never far away I
love my Helix and I think that you would
too if you're looking for a new bed
check out Helix you can click the link
below or go to helixsleep.com inside
Marvel to get 20 off your Helix mattress
plus two free pillows that's
helixsleep.com inside Marvel so this is
where we're getting into Bob iger's
restructuring plan and this is where
we're getting into the MIDI the knitting
rubber tiger
yeah we're getting to Robbie cool trains
restructuring plants so I mentioned
earlier and we've been talking about a
little bit the CEO Bob Iger who's
restructuring a lot of Disney right now
as soon as he came back his like come
back return they're starting to focus on
quality over quantity and that would
reduce the cost on some films and TV
shows so how could that affect Marvel's
VFX and the Marvel Studios overall
because they're not only like doing it
they're not only applying this
structuring to just like Marvel it's
also to Star it's lucasfilms it's Star
Wars It's to Disney overall it's Disney
Parks but they did mention a lot with
like Marvel how it's like these great
characters are amazing but do they need
like three movies do they need four
movies maybe we can just go back down to
putting them in a one big Avengers movie
which I think vosh you were kind of
mentioning with like Echo not getting
her own series but being in the
Forefront for like Kang Dynasty or
Secret Wars yeah uh and you know we I
should just be clear this is just my
thinking I there as far as we know Echo
is still going to come out as a series
um but I think what um what we all have
to recognize in terms of budget is even
though something has wrapped on
production yes that's a lot of money
we're talking to the millions that they
probably spent on that
we use the Hollywood map used to be
whatever the budget of some of the
announce project is double it in terms
of overall cost because the other half
of that comes from the marketing of it
um really now we're talking about triple
it because the other third of it comes
from the VFX budget that has to go into
it so even though something has wrapped
you still save a buttload of money if
you were to cut I know I'm thinking like
freaking like a crazy man right now cut
these things I'm not making an argument
for Disney to cut these things because I
still want to see them I'm just saying
from Bob iger's perspective yeah you cut
a lot of costs by not having to like
spend all that money on VFX on reshoots
on paying these actors to come back and
rebuild the sets and put them on
location uh on whatever because the
thing is the the amount of money they're
spending on the cast of these things
they're not paying the actors that much
they keep hiring new casts they're not
paying Tom Cruise to be on set it'd be
different if it was Robert Downey Jr
whose project where you had to pay him a
ton at the front end uh it's not the
same dealio and I think what that's why
you're starting to hear things now that
there's a Mephisto special presentation
that works they might have signed a deal
with Sasha Baron Cohen at the front and
they have to put him in something and
now they're like okay it'll be cheaper
just to shoot a special presentation
than it will be to continue uh working
on editing reshooting these episodes of
ironheart to make it make sense and to
make it really good that's not that's
why I'm just starting to read behind the
between the lines here speaking of like
special presentations I think I feel
like we might be seeing more of those
more so than full shows
um you know because like you know there
are less VFX intensive like Eric was
saying and it's just like it just makes
sense considering that you know like
presentations like werewolf by night
getting like so much praise and like so
much love and that's like a short little
bubble story and I feel like people like
seeing Marvel but like they you don't
necessarily need a whole 8 or 18 episode
season where with VFX to do that and I
think that we might be seeing more or
just really short stories of like here's
this new character here's wolf by night
here's a man thing story here's here's
so and so to like enter to get more um
Heroes into the MCU without having to
invest in like a full movie or a full TV
show so I I be done for more special
presentations because I love them I
enjoyed werewolf By Night more than I
enjoyed Moon Knight
oh like I now I don't know that's why if
midnight was better business you gotta
imagine Moon night with Oscar Isaac six
episodes of it probably got more
subscribers on Disney plus than werewolf
by night did but if we're talking about
like some of these lower tier series I
like what about like I enjoyed uh Ms
Marvel probably more than I enjoyed
werewolf by night but like did it do as
good a business you know as some of
these other Disney Plus shows like if
you're looking at it purely from a
cold-hearted Solace business mindset if
you're committed to releasing some of
these titles could you release echo or
ironheart as a one shot not a special
presentation that's what I think is
really difficult to think of two things
difficult to think about with a special
presentation because not only did like
the special presentation Premiere in
like LA on 35 millimeter film so it's
pulling in people that aren't
necessarily superhero fans so would Miss
Marvel as a special presentation get as
much as werewolf by night I don't know
because it's also werewolf by night was
was uh like marketed as like kind of a
horror Thriller and it was very violent
so it's like appeasing to an audience
that isn't really a superhero audience
but could be because it's a part of the
MCU so it's like that special
presentation was so specific and I think
the same would apply to um Mephisto
Sasha bear Cohen doing a special
presentation because it's going to be
more about like not hell specifically
but it's gonna be like not not
metaphysical what is the word like uh
witchy it's gonna be witchy it's gonna
be the underworld and I think that
darkness is what people kind of really
get to and maybe they're going to be
following that suit with werewolf by
night I think special presentations are
cheaper to do for sure uh and we should
take as much advantage of them as
possible and then we can release them in
small theaters and then they would just
be great but this kind of ties into the
third question of and what more ways
than one can we see Marvel's
restructuring and because it's gonna be
like it's not gonna be major things I
mean I think these like pushes that
we're seeing go so far are are kind of
directly connected to what's happening
with the restructuring plan I think uh
special presentations will also be a
part of the restructuring plan because
they're like Bob iger's like we don't
need to do three four five movies off
this one character we can give you a
special presentation or get you like
them showing up and appearing as a cameo
in another episode so koi mentioned that
we're gonna stick to more grounded
things than in space things and that's
why they're giving Daredevil a lot of
episodes and I'm like yeah Daredevil
problem is a lot easier a lot on the
budget than like eternals would be so
sticking to those Heroes that are ground
Fighters that don't need too much like
werewolf by night where everything was
more practical of him throwing people uh
they might actually get into Michael
Waldron being a new writer deal like he
they have to go through Michael
Waldron's ideas he's going to be an
in-house writer it's easier to grab him
uh lucasfilms using them for sound what
are other ways that we're gonna see them
restructure but maybe that we wouldn't
know that everyone would notice sorry
that's a big question and I I I answered
like two of them by saying lucasfilms
and Michael Waldron we're gonna see the
Guardians uh flying in the Millennium
Falcon instead um just to save money uh
they already have it on set I'm just
kidding my expectation is that they are
going to invest more in the talent that
they already have contracts with and
putting them in interesting situations
and letting a team of creatives just
work their magic as opposed to investing
in new talent that people don't know and
throwing VFX at them
um we go back to like I think those are
at least Studio Lessons Learned From
Miss Marvel from uh just 2022 Miss
Marvel Moon Knight and She-Hulk all
three had new talent in them and yeah
people who know Oscar Isaac not as many
people know Tatiana maslani not as many
people no one really knew Iman villani
uh but all three of those shows they
just threw the effects at these things
to varying degrees of success uh and
expected that formula to be winning and
it didn't I don't think I I don't think
that worked uh with the hardcore MCU
hands it did bring in some new audiences
uh but it I don't think it moved the
needle with subscribers on Disney plus
but what did work is some
experimentation with one Division and
with Loki those are long time MCU actors
and they partnered with them with really
talented writers and really talented
directors and really talented production
designers uh and came up with some
really great I think Loki is like
anomalistic I think that was just like
they had a great concept for that show
but like one Division I feel like is
replicable that's why I think Agatha the
coven of Chaos
Mephisto and other kind of like cheeky
uh TV history titles like vision quest
uh or or wonder man could work yeah I
agree I I think but it's also my my
thinking and this is not logical is what
happens when they're trying to leave or
they do die because even like how we
felt with Ant-Man it's like yeah there's
a piece of me that was like I wanted
Ant-Man to die at the end of quantumania
so what happens when our the people that
have made like a real big indent have to
die or just need to leave and I think
that's what we got with phase four was
it's like okay these stories are kind of
wrapping up we need to get a new bundle
so maybe is that what we're going to be
seeing from Marvel going forward is it's
gonna go like up and then down and then
up and then down again because it's like
they don't need to add any new
characters we got like seven new ones
from phase four so you're good you're
good for now don't add any more but
eventually those seven will go on or
pass away or pass the mantle
um 10 years from now so in that 10 years
are we gonna get new characters and just
go back down to a plateau I don't think
they have to kill them off
um I don't think I think they're as you
said just there are plenty there are
plenty Lenny introduced just in the
first year of phase four like I don't
understand why they announce an echo
spin-off series before we say Shang Chi
is getting a fighting tournament series
shenzhi was such a huge hit everyone
knew it in September 2021 why two months
later did they're like before anyone had
even known really who Echo was from
Hawkeye or they're like we're gonna do
an echo series that doesn't make sense
to me like that's why I think like
shenzhi was such a hit everyone wants
some Chi fighting tournament do announce
a 10 Ring series coming Disney plus 2023
and you're gonna get a huge wave of
subscribers like there's just so many
weird I get that you don't have access
to the X-Men yet I get that but like you
have obvious wins coming out of phase
one and like they're still like we need
to bring in different people who no one
has any attachment to and give them uh
Eight Episodes it's hard because uh she
also a lot of uh she's been credited of
Victoria Alonso for bringing the
diversity into Marvel's uh Studios and
so it's like did she I agree I if I had
to choose between Echo I would probably
choose Xiang Chi he was such a great
character such a great movie but it's
like do you think they
we're pushing for Echo because we don't
really have a lot of Native American
representation in the Cinematic Universe
and a lot of phase four is built on
diversity uh not even in race and gender
in sexuality and so I'm like I love the
initiative but it does seem like you
guys are jumping before you even look
like looking before you go and push
these projects because I don't want Echo
to be set up for a disaster I don't want
you guys to speed on this before we even
have a handle on it give her a good
platform give her a good jumping point
and right now it just seems like you
guys are just trying to push it out and
not really thinking about the story or
where she could go perfectly yeah or why
not introduce Echo as part as a warrior
in a fighting tournament in a ten ring
show you have Echo it's like a vocal
character in a tendering show team her
up with shung Chi and the two of them
are fighting in the 10 Rings tournament
that is how you set it up for Success
right no she's a great warrior and then
give her the show I agree with Eric 100
because like I feel like
it like having characters that were
introduced in a movie versus having a
character that was introduced in a TV
show that not everyone watched like
Hawkeye
um I feel like might do Echo
um a little bit of a disservice like
whereas if Echo was introduced in Sheng
Chi as this badass person then people be
like oh yo there's an echo show coming
out like let's see what she's all about
and um because there's more eyes on that
character on a big screen versus I'm a
TV show so I feel like maybe I mean
hopefully in the future
um we'll see like more so of that the
introductions of those characters that
do get their own TV show in a movie
versus
um
um a pro a TV in Project yeah I feel
this way about ironheart too like you
can have uh Riri Williams as like the
technological competitor in this
fighting tournament and then they each
get their own episode The Way Monica
Rambo and one division had her her own
episode that flashed back to her past
and it was so great it's like lost like
every episode of the first season of
lost you flash back to the past it's
like a classic TV structure way to
introduce characters Yellowjackets is
doing a great job of this I think
Severance did a great job with point of
view uh Ted lasso did this really well
with uh with Nate and uh giving him
certain episodes and able to build him
up like you can have fighting tournament
episodes where each episode you have
like reread flashing back to Chicago and
she's building uh her and she's
dealing with the hood and then you can
just have like different spotlights each
episode while giving putting them into
context that viewers care about yeah oh
for sure it's so hard because I mean we
have no notes to give to Marvel that's
like we don't know how it works we
didn't how are we supposed to know that
Echo wasn't going to be as major as and
then these people that come up with
these ideas they come out right after
the property comes out so it's like they
because they shot it right and then you
get like six months till it comes out
and then you get like the four months to
choose whether or not you want to go
with the second version of it or a
spin-off or something else so you don't
really get that opportunity to really
sit down and chew on it you kind of just
have to like should we do it or should
we not do it and it's like we're gonna
do it and it didn't really land for a
lot of people or not land but more so
like just didn't give us enough meat
give us enough meat to chew on yet
um so with the final question for this
inside marble overall you guys will
there be a new Victoria Alonso will
there be a new head of visual effects
with what we said with Robert Iger
restructuring
um will they just I I laugh at this they
can't put Kevin feige as a head of
visual effects you can't you can't
sorry my bad everyone knows what's
happening with the VFX with Marvel we
all are aware of it there's no there's
no hiding it they have a they're these
poor people are working themselves to
death making these visual effects for
them uh there's so many movies that
require so much visual effects that it's
like
they need a new Victoria Alonso right
they like not even because she left we
need someone else in that position they
can't be there'll be a bunch of chickens
with their head cut off right well yeah
yeah like there there has to be a new
Victoria Alonso because like at the end
of the day like the VFX Department of
any comic book universe is the heart of
the universe in my opinion because like
they're that's essentially the the art
of the art the comic book essentially
um like without VFX there is nothing and
I feel like
um when they do get a new Victoria
Alonso
um that person really has to prioritize
giving these VFX workers more time and
um just listening to them and like you
just be like hey what do you need to
give us the best products
um in like working together with them
rather than being like we need this done
by eight o'clock tonight or I need to
see the she-hulks uh detail on their
face
um immediately
um and you know it's just like I just
want these people to be to feel happy
going to work and not not to feel
stressed that because crunch is unfun
um and like I just don't like workers
being crunched I'm in general so like if
there's news Victoria Alonso which there
will be because there has to be
um I hope hopefully they prioritize that
yeah I think um I think we're all
probably feeling a bit out of our depth
right now because we're talking about
like Studio business synergistic
structure and hires and things like that
but I think what they do need is to
bring in-house this VFX operation to
where you have an artist making the
decisions so they need to hire the head
of WETA or the head of Cantina or the
head of frame store to to oversee this
operation someone who is an artist who
understands the needs who is in a
healthy positive partnership with this
with the executive team so uh like I
think what we really need more than like
a new Victoria Alonso is we just need
like a new position a new way to think
about the way this is organized
um and so that like you can bring in
Nate Moore and Brad winterbaum and these
other guys uh and they have like a
healthy that position might already
exist in-house at Marvel but we need to
like what you what you see at Pixar what
you see at lucasfilm are those artists
are working for the studio they have it
in-house so they're all like excited to
work on these projects
um it's uh like it almost makes more
sense to bring in someone who's head of
stunts like bring in one of these these
stuff coordination teams in-house so
that they have an at Disney email
address that can go to the parks for
free with their families you know like
100 stop pitting these companies against
each other to be contractors and make
them all imagineers yeah yes they need I
think it's also they need they have a
Victoria Alonso they need someone in
between Victoria Alonso and that you saw
how long her title was she's not only
doing visual effects she was doing
product physical production you need
someone else to do the physical
production that also has this background
in visual effects that knows how to make
it work and so maybe it's just like
restructure Disney restructure all you
need but think about your employees
first okay that's it for the episode of
inside Marvel reminder to subscribe to
the Deep dive Channel at Deep dive NR
follow me at Lulu underscore Clemons
follow Eric at EA Vos and follow MTF
Master attainment subscribe to inside
Marvel wherever you get your podcast and
thanks for watching we'll see you later
hey gay
[Music]